-Our first guest tonight
is a Golden Globe-winning
and Emmy-nominated actress
who you know
from her work in "Alias"
and movies like
"13 Going on 30,"
"Juno,"
and "Dallas Buyers Club."
She stars in the new film
"Yes Day,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-How about this?
If you say no one time,
I get to go to Flea Fest
with Layla.
No adults, no parents.
Just us young, underage,
vulnerable girls.
-Wait, honey, are you sure
-I'll take your wager, missy
because I know that
I won't say no.
And when you lose --
and you will lose --
I am so fun that you will stil
get to go to your concert.
-Really?
-Absolutely.
With me!
I'm gonna sit right next to yo
and we're gonna hold hands
and we're gonna put our hands in
the air like we just don't care.
-Please welcome back
to the show
the wonderful Jennifer Garner.
How are you, Jennifer?
-Hi, Seth. How you doing?
-I'm doing well.
It's so nice to see you.
It was so nice to see you
on the cover of
"The Hollywood Reporter."
You look so full of joy,
so vibrant, so full of life.
And yet I saw you doing
some other promotion
on the "Hot Ones" YouTube show
where you eat hotter and hotte
chicken wings.
Did you enjoy that experience?
I've done it as well.
I both enjoyed it and hated it
How did you feel?
-I don't know
how I felt about it.
I mean, he gives
such a great interview.
-He does.
-He's so smart.
But them my mouth blew up,
and we had to, like, pace --
I had to ice it because
these things, they got --
I had issues. I had definite -
-Yeah.
-It looks like I had been
sunburned or punched or --
-My issue was afterwards.
People said, "Drink a lot of
milk and eat two bagels,"
and then that was
a whole nother thing.
It was not a good 24-hour period
for me.
-[ Laughs ] Yes. It wasn't -
I'm too old for that, is
basically what we learned. Yeah.
-So, this movie is
based on a book.
And it is a book that not only
did you produce the film,
but this is a book you used to
read to it your kids, right?
-I used to read "Yes Day!" b
Amy Krouse Rosenthal to my kids.
We adopted yes days
before they were a thing.
I think the whole world was kind
of quietly starting to do them
And then we made a movie of it
So here it is.
-And basically, the premis
behind this is parents
having to say yes to everythin
their kids come up with.
And you actually did this with
your kids, your real-life kids
-I did, but I kind of would --
I would kind of set it up.
I mean, the movie sets it up
like you should have
these big asks.
It's really colorful
wish fulfillment,
the most fun, joyful version
I kind of set it up
with my kids like,
"Hey, maybe you should ask for
a picnic," you know?
And they were like, "Okay.
Now, I am scared for
our next yes day.
And parents who have
watched this movie
are like, "Oh, my gosh."
And I say, "No, just go,
you know, at your own pace."
Would you ever do it?
-I think if I had two girl
I would do it, but my boys are
idiots and I would be very -
[ Laughter ]
I'd be very skeptical of
whatever they would
plan for the day.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Yeah, smart
-Plus, my 2-year-old
is very hard to understand
And I feel like I would do
everything he asks,
and then at the end of the day
he'd be like,
"This was all the opposite
You got it totally wrong."
-Yeah.
-You did some things in the film
that are outside of
your comfort zone.
So, even though you set it u
for your kids, in the movie,
which you were in control of
you do look genuinely unhapp
to be on this roller coaster
-I was so miserable.
Most of that footage
of the take --
this is called the Twisted
Colossus at Magic Mountain
It is not something
I would ever do,
even on a yes day.
My own children would not ask me
to do something this odious.
And I did it.
I wrote it --
We wrote it into the movie
and then the time came,
and suddenly I had to get on
that stupid thing.
I cried, I cussed, I made
the whole thing unusable.
We had to shoot it again.
Yeah, it wasn't
my proudest moment.
I mean, look at that poor girl
-So is this something as someone
growing up, did you also
not like roller coasters?
-No. I was fine.
It's just as I've gotten -
I mean, I used to
jump off buildings.
I used to be, you know --
Nothing scared me.
And now I've just gotten
a little more like,
"Oh, you only get one life
and it's precious.
And don't jump off of buildings,
maybe."
-See, I wouldn't worry I would
die on a roller coaster,
but I've definitely reached th
age where I might hurt my neck
in a way that would
last 19 months.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-You also sang in the movie,
and it's something we definitely
have in common.
I do not like singing.
You put yourself through that.
How was it?
-I do not like singing
in front of people.
-No, no.
-I like singing to my kids
I like singing at church,
you know.
I'm fine with a lullaby.
But singing in front of people
was miserable.
I had to play the ukulele, and
I've never played the ukulele.
The only string instrument
I know -- I played the violi
at school long enough
that my mom finally said,
"Jennifer, would you please quit
the violin?"
'Cause she said, "I can't listen
to it anymore, honey.
I don't think you're ever
going to get better."
And so I did.
I don't know if it came
in handy, my violin gifts,
but I did spend, you know,
weeks and months,
especially over Christmas break,
obsessing with the ukulele
And, luckily, I could
focus on that.
And I could say to the crowd
before I sang in front of them
"Look, I don't know what's
going to happen. I don't know.
I'm so scared, I could pee
I don't know.
We're just going to have t
get through it together."
-[ Laughs ]
Now, does that mean that
you are someone who,
in your normal life,
does not like karaoke?
-The problem -- Okay.
Let's get serious about this
The problem with karaoke is --
-Let me just jump in
and tell you
I'm so enthusiastic about
your tone,
and I can just tell
you're going to be right.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
The songs are all too --
Nobody needs the full song
One verse, one chorus, be done
If you get to the bridge,
you have gone too far.
-Yeah. My thing is
when my friends say,
"Hey, we should do karaoke,"
I'll say, "How about
we'll get in an Uber,
and you guys sing
whatever you want,
and then we'll get to a plac
that doesn't have karaoke?
We'll just karaoke in the ca
and then go to a bar
where we can have a conversation
like adults."
-I never want to go to karaoke
-Yeah.
-If I am with you guys,
can we agree to not go to
karaoke together?
-Of course,
and it's always your friends
who can sing who are like,
"Let's go do karaoke."
It's like being with
a bunch of --
if all your friends were tal
and they're like,
"Should we do basketball
tonight?"
And you're like,
"I don't want to do basketball."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-"Why do we always do
basketball?
Why do you guys decide?"
Hey, I want to ask, before
we go, you have chickens,
which you're very kind
to share on social media.
How many chickens are you at
right now?
-I think we're down to nine.
But they keep --
they keep living,
even after they're done
being cute.
-So, when you say down to nine
what's bringing
the number down?
-Death, Seth.
-Yeah. Noted.
-Yeah, death.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no, we had 13.
We had a baker's dozen.
But I mean, we've had them
for six years.
-Oh, I see. I gotcha.
-Yeah, and they're suppose
to live
between one and three
if you're not eating them.
-Oh, wow. Alright. Gotcha.
-And so these guys -- I have
a bunch of grandma chickens,
but they're not, you know --
they're not going anywhere
-You should bring them
on that roller coaster.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like it would not
go well for them.
-I'm going to bring them to you,
for your sons.
You need them.
-Hey, it's always a pleasure
to see you.
Congrats on the movie, and loo
forward to the next time.
-Thank you. Great to see you
Thank you so much, Seth.